I were live we're live in five four
three hello guys I'm Ryan Wright and I
am Jerry uh today we're gonna check out
the world premiere trailer for preacher
yeah I imagine the preacher talks like
this he's a creepy [ __ ] that one
hey well is it me I suggest for himself
creepy no he's not that's not at all how
he sounds they got the duo that we
expected Seth Rogen Evan Goldberg that's
who we expected to adapt this okay and
now we're here
I'm excited actually they seem like a
like an interesting dude yeah because
you did I don't think I don't expect
them to put their you know like super
bad style spin on it but they seem like
like they're interested they're good
boys onra they're part of this wave of
comedians now who are interested in
doing stuff that's a little more outside
I would say their work is inspiring to
me to like editor write likes to do Jon
rakamma Dee and I feel like Seth Rogen
and Evan Goldberg you know what their
line of this is the end it's kind of
like an apocalyptic comedy a horror
comedy pineapple Express which is like
an action soda exactly yeah
and then even they even did the Green
Hornet which you didn't get the best
feedback but that in itself was a
different kind of movie and I feel like
they could totally add that are rated
flare to the two preacher because
cultures and creeds are NDErs hell yeah
it's an aggressive dirty [ __ ] comic
without space weird dark humor to it an
ID SM cop I feel like they could do it
there is what you won't get what you
want about my dad I want you to hurt him
you know it's a sin just to ask me that
people said before you were a preacher
you did things
how are you wanted
how far'd will go
problem is your daddy's a big fella he's
good far back
things'll escalate that's what these
things do they escalate violence thinks
violence makes nothing but you know
breacher it up almost done Sheriff
another than the note so you won't keep
chances what kind of a preacher you [ __ ]
feels more grounded than I thought it
would be I thought it would be a lot
more out there you know I'm curious
about yeah I mean like this is this is a
very now sort of trailer exactly and I
this may be just me reading my hopes and
dreams into it but like it almost seems
like this is hiding something that's a
little more flavor a little more laughs
I I was totally getting that vibe yeah
watch it the whole time like okay I get
what they're doing it's the first
trailer they're providing like the
serious intense tease at the tone of the
violence and stuff but I feel like a
second trailer can really do this good
justice and it totally looks like an AMC
show oh yeah
it like looks like AMC AMC crashed into
the El Rey Network in a way yeah you can
totally see that a good way it's not
like exactly what I was expecting from
the tonin and that kid is in wet hot
American summer I wasn't expected to be
so serious and they didn't even really
show us I like is it gonna have like the
angels and the demons and stuff I'm not
really getting like I didn't get a
supernatural vibe at all from this or
you know religious type of supernatural
vibe well I don't remember how crazy
like like creature II the show gets or
if it gets really like like she said the
book okay this whole history though is
he's the son of genesis though well yeah
yeah yeah I have to see it's been so
long since I've read it so it's like I
didn't remember it being like a super
fantasy like it seemed like it was more
sort of a grungy Neela sticker with
version totally and it was [ __ ]
brutal to what I'm getting a vibe of is
like the six sinister type of
personalities out there that's what I'm
really picking up on which is cool I
don't feel like there's a really unique
hook yet that they've shown us yeah the
fact that he's a preacher who's kind of
like you know he's like a rebellious
preacher or some [ __ ] like Y Z's you
know you're you're sort of paradoxical
preacher galleries like he's not a good
guy
he's kind of but I mean that's a good
one that makes sense guys character
because he's both pure good and evil I
would say the trailer did a really good
job at depicting the preacher character
himself Jesse Custer yeah you know I
mean it's very sparse yeah I'll get
excited when I see something else yeah
like you know this is pretty cool I mean
you know it's like all the stuff we've
come to expect from a hard-hitting you
know cable show it's uh here's some
intensity interspersed with really
violent violence the one thing that's
kind of letting me down about what we I
saw was I'm not getting the special
touch of Seth Rogen and Evan Goldberg
being behind us well yeah that's the
thing this this trailer doesn't have
there's no ha no right now a lot of
personnel what is your yeah what is your
personality like that's what I'm
wondering now it's like I know what
you're Pope content is gonna be rough
yeah but what is your personality great
way to put it very well worded you can
guide your sexy with your language you
know I picked up some words I love to
[ __ ] your mouth don't do that without my
express written permission and the
permission of the NFL I feel like we
need to stop complaining the teaser
trailer didn't show us the entire story
if you know enough to know what preacher
is then why do you care yeah because
there's gonna be a lot of people who are
going to be pissed off when they see
this trailer because they're gonna be
like hardcore preacher fans preacher is
more than just the character it's the
world yeah and that's what I felt like
we were I mean it's called preacher so I
guess if you're appealing to a
demographic or like an audience who
doesn't know because they're not as
preachers not a big of a comic as like a
marble yeah yeah we get in movies now
you know it's a more pulpy more sort of
cult comedy yeah I don't know changing
major plot points around like yeah you
want to know if they're gonna do that
but especially for a teaser for a show
like this I feel like the more important
thing is for them to show you the tone
I still feel though that preacher is not
it seems like they're moving at a pace
like the walking dead moves at I don't
feel that when I read the comic though I
don't know I get from dusk till dawn I'm
from this in terms of like this the
pacing of the show in terms of the basis
on show kind of takes its time but it
still gets pulpy and like that's kind of
what this feels like
whereas Walking Dead is like a drama and
then occasionally zombies I think they
should
next trailer they got to release more
personality in the yeah they got to show
some of the angel and demon [ __ ] that's
a big thing that I think a lot of people
are gonna want to get something of or at
least like Lisa promised Mary that it'll
show an outlandish dirty southern
personality is it's like when I read
preacher and then I hear Seth Rogen and
Evan Goldberg or are you gonna do it I'm
like you know what some people might
think that's an unorthodox choice but I
could see how we could work well yeah I
know I it seems like they're just trying
to do what other shows have already done
well I am see is trying to end me you
know they're they're thinking about
their marketing machine and what works
yeah stuff and you know AMC has had some
flop shows so I'm sure they want to
market this to look kind of like
whatever they're successful yeah that's
true like was saying earlier like you
got to appeal to a much bigger
demographic now than just the comic fans
yeah and I mean that's the thing is like
I like Seth Rogen and Evan Goldberg on
this because you know it's it's an
interesting choice to me it's like oh
they must have cared to get this made
cuz you know I mean it's not the most
marketable property I think that that
little tag on the end with [ __ ] though I
always forget his name the Irish guy
that little tag on the end suggests to
me that there will probably be some some
quippy dialogue ins yeah with on rhythm
because that characters around a lot in
the book like you know it yeah because
my biggest issue so far it's like I get
it's a teaser trailer like I was even
watching the trailer for the Martian
today yeah and I was like this trailers
a lot more serious than the movie
actually is I get an impression that
this show will probably be a lot more
fun I'm hoping a little know I hope
because this trailer to me doesn't even
convey the personality of the comic
Reacher has like that like vampires and
[ __ ] like eat one of his buddies as a
vampire
yeah wasn't that the Irish guy it might
be eyes like I said is I read this when
I was like uh turret yeah I read this
many years ago two in a long time yeah I
should like I wanna I want to revisit
this will probably give me the juice I
need to do it but yeah I mean you know
it's it this teaser is certainly missing
a lot of stuff I can give you the juice
you need please don't
give you that you needed at my skin it's
fine again I'm just curious see because
you know ANSI they've had some
difficulty between their showrunners and
they're you know producers I don't know
at this point like it's a teaser and
it's you can tell the beats it's like oh
we drew from this one intense scene
where somebody's making a challenging
request and then we're gonna enter
splice you know violence and stuff like
it's a trailer I've seen so many dams
that it's like I'm almost like okay and
like let's see something different now
with preconceived notions being put to
the side finally for me I do gotta say
really cool monologue I did like the
monologue it's like if I have never
heard a preacher or read the comic I
would have seen this and been like that
show does look pretty cool actually not
like enough for me to be like I have to
tune in but I'm willing to check it out
this is an OK teaser in the sense that
it's like I'm interested in seeing more
like yeah you've got my attention you
know yeah yeah I'm not like I gotta see
this now because like the Evil Dead
teaser or the evil that trailer they
released is like ah like I get what's
going on and this is sort of like I'm
interested let's see what else you got
AMC tends to get good DPS and I think
the cinematography looks pretty good too
oh yeah I mean I have no I have no doubt
that this show look great that's where
it kind of reminded me of the look of
The Walking Dead - yeah where's the
waves DP'd what even Breaking Bad has
that - or it was like look at how much
desolate landscape there is like look
how tiny these people are in relation to
their environment I guess it's like
[ __ ] ANC they do like that see they do
like dusty places AMC um well they
actually are sponsoring this video and a
lot of people don't know what AMC stands
for yeah it stands for All My Children
American mother's [ __ ] the biggest [ __ ]
who was an American mother formed AMC
now he agree shows like Britney bad
Walking Dead Season feeling very long
time yeah took her so long I don't know
I mean just her contact to produce some
amazing content or content I just read
AMC and I want her to say the word
connor anyway guys if you're new to the
channel you can click this button today
and subscribe to become
reject teacher ooh
the dad sounds like a reject teacher
like you dear a shitty teacher and now
your yeah acted from Teachers Union yeah
sup mr. Motta hmm oh he's a good dude
he's a good dude you could do sensing
which time flexor your biceps as a third
grade teacher my friend wrong thing to
do to kids reasons to Jerry and Dan cast
observe your playlists on this channel
hosted by said Jer bear and yeah yeah
let's do a shout-out to a [ __ ]
Jonathan Jonathan Holly hey Ryan I've
been watching your channel for about a
year now
great stuff I was wondering if he could
give me a shout-out to my youtube
channel super one two zero five eight he
has a channel trailer and shale tray
let's do this we're gonna do a reaction
for you oh that's our shoutout
like After Effects
pew what the [ __ ] is your channel about
you call it a channel trailer I have no
[ __ ] clue what your channel is about
all I saw was a guy who likes to mess
with editing program I mean they were it
looked like they were gonna have a
battle or something today it was one guy
yeah but in many forms you don't know
the story what if the story is like he's
all they're all clones and they're you
know tasked with being this service I
don't know I don't know
look dude this has nothing to do with
the fact that I'm jealous that he's
really good at making effects in his
videos and doing [ __ ] I have no clue how
to do trust me I mean that is not
interfering with my judgement of the
channel trailer okay I [ __ ] you man I
totally accept you man I was wrong I
take it back man yeah can you forgive me
yeah you know why they call me Ryan
right why you Ryan wrong yeah dude that
was a cool that was a cool channel
trailer man I feel like you're up to
some good things that you have the
equipment and content to be able to put
something together so stay persistent
stay consistent and I'm gonna be
insistent that you stay that way okay
Micro wrap and stay black being blacks
great I've done it before have you yeah
how does you magic marker oh it just
colored oh no no that's a joke just for
the black subs they know I'm just
[ __ ] around brother